so leute, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, seid ho-ups
seit heute gibt es 8 terabyte ssd für sagenhafte 848 euro vorzubestellen
endlich, ich wollte schon immer mal knapp 1000 euro ausgeben für eine ssd
poggers, das den fehler mache ich nicht nochmal wie gesagt ich habe mir ja von
paar jahren eine 2 terabyte ssd bestellt als die noch ganz ganz neu waren oder 4 terabyte
nee 2 terabyte 2 terabyte ssd als sie noch nagelneu waren für irgendwie 56 euro oder so und jetzt
kostet eine 2 terabyte gibt es gar nicht mehr so klein ist doch sehr kostet 2 terabyte ssd
202 drittel drittel noch davon er ja aber es kann ich meine es ist eine kuvo es ist
ein bisschen langsamer aber 8 terabyte ist schon ordentlich ja da kannst du gar mal den
warfare drauf installieren excellent schnappchen ein schnapper ja wahrlich ein wahrlicher schnapper
weil irgendjemand gefragt hat ob der peper auch bei ihm im terminal tanzt du hast mich
auf eine idee gebracht gibt es nicht gibt es nicht play play gifs terminal gibt es da
nicht irgendwas für how to play gif in your terminal oder wie die coolen leute ja sagen
auch wenn es nicht stimmt jeff jeff ok wie geht das wie kann ich gifs im terminal playen
gif gif for cli ok das gibt es bestimmt gif cli aber ich bin auf dem alten system fällt
mir gerade auf gif for cli das ist von 2018 da gibt es bestimmt was neueres how to play
gif files in ubuntu jubantu snap igit snap machen ok das müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren
das müssen wir ausprobieren ich starte mal neu jetzt hast du mich auf eine idee gebracht
ich muss jetzt ausprobieren wie man gifs ich muss unbedingt ausprobieren wie man gifs
im terminal abspielen kann max bait hat uns halt jepp nicht als emote nee hab ich nicht
weil jepp ein kacke emote ist jepp ist das schlechteste emote überhaupt die musik ist
immer noch zu laut ne können sich wieder nicht entscheiden können sich wieder nicht entscheiden
ob der stream lauter oder eiser also wie ist das ding jetzt gif cli could not find all
required packages haben wir den snap drauf ok ich glaub nicht warum soll ich einen container
installieren für so einen kacke oh das ist von google gif force hier das ist von google
das ist ein google programm ok das wusste ich nicht 0w hat das auch releases wo ist
denn jetzt der releases tab ach nee dann da neben paper dance gif ich muss das noch mal
runterladen ja high res nee wo ist mein high wo ist mein high res what the hell wo ist
mein high res paper dance das da nee hallo transparent das da ha ist das high res das
ist high res excellent safe paper please so und jetzt müssen wir gleich mal gucken wie
man das abspielen kann installieren wir das halt hier drüber ok could not find ich will
doch nur den den kram installieren kann ich so schwierig sein dr pro pro noob stufe eins
excellent dankeschön für den sub ok man kann vielleicht vielleicht sollte ich mal
updaten schon eine weile nicht mehr geupdatet wobei nee wir haben erst den letzten stream
des ledigungs geupdatet erst firefox ok mach der download ist mega langsam gerade was ist
mit unity media bestimmt unity media im zweifelsfall immer unity media flame wenn sie auch wenn
es wahrscheinlich den mirror ist snap cli gif gif cli warum muss sie warum muss ich
das echt mit dem snap machen doch voll bescheuert oder was gibt es sonst noch für varianten
ich kann das auch so machen das ist aber einfach nur pipp ich habe ich habe noch nicht mal
heißen geduld ist hier drauf da war es doch gif cli was hat er für schmerzen jetzt aber
existi haben wir es heute noch mal snap alda das ist wirklich monka pepehands die kombination
so ok das ist das ist aber nicht das von google gif cli das ist aber nicht das von google
gif er hat es nicht runtergeladen er hat mir nur den link zum bild meine güte eh downloads
sind auch nicht mehr das was sie mal waren ich will ich wollte einfach nur pippe please
download aber nee pippe please ok pippe please gif und das und das ganze hires ich hab angst
die google bildersuche zu verwenden bei sowas eh animated gif das ist doch gut hier eh das
ist zu klein color transparent das hier hires das hier ist hires view image ne das ist nicht
das ist nicht animated wo hatte ich es daneben alda wo hatte ich es daneben pippe dance transparent
ah hier ok jetzt view image save image pippe please gif cli what kann man das neuer nix
nicht mehr runterladen oder was was ist das ok das muss ein gif sein das muss ein gif
ok was ist das für ein kackprogramm oder was macht das denn das displayed auf jeden
fall das ganze schon mal nicht bin ich jetzt total verwirrt was zum liegt bestimmt an
snapd ach moment das sucht einfach nur nach gifs das sucht einfach nur nach gifs oh man
das ist gar nicht das programm was wir haben was ich haben wollte wie ist das ach nee das
ist ja obuntu taktik das ist remove ok play gif cli das ist gar nicht gedacht dass das
so schwierig ist snap ich habe gesehen dass es das als snap gibt anscheinend nicht ok
jetzt habt ihr jetzt hat mich der weiß ich mal wer es geschrieben hat hat mich jetzt
echt auf die ich will jetzt ich will jetzt ich will jetzt mal gif abspielen auf der kommando
zeile also über also über den paket manager installieren geht schon mal nicht weil das
weil das kein bock hat das mag nicht so dann installieren das jetzt über google da muss
wir erst mal installieren und und pyson zeug wo ist es denn pyson pipp 10 ich installiere
jetzt erst mal das halbe internet durch gifs auf der kommando zeile abspielen kann was
man die alles macht aha aha excellent was braucht man sonst noch ffm pack setlip pyson
set up tools ok was auch immer ok mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert gif gif for cli und
jetzt pippe please oh es ist big brain das muss erst mal processen ha da ist es es funktioniert
das sieht das sieht relativ gut aus kann man das loopen lassen kann man das loopen lassen
loop loop das hat doch bestimmt in loop oder minus l null repeat forever minus l null jawoll
so gefällt mir das jetzt haben wir auch pippe please auf dem terminal das hat die welt gebraucht
das ist doch wahrlich excellent das in kombination mit unserem big brain gif was kann es besseres
geben max mach mal rare parrot hast du das mal in ordentlicher qualität ok moment gucken
wir mal das andere party parrot da gab es auch diese seite cult of party parrot genau
also wer mal besonders viele animierte papagei gifs braucht man kann mit dem tool suchen
echt search wie sucht man aber dann nur mit ap key wie macht man einen query wie sucht
man oder einfach nur parrot oh leute ich hab angst was da jetzt kommt ich mach mal klein
ich hab angst was da jetzt kommt es könnte auch ascii art ascii art kann auch gegen twitch
toss sein man weiß ja nie ups nein im monka toss nicht monka db ja das ist der papagei
party parrot ich bin ja echt begeistert dass es so ein tool gibt und was ich noch viel
geiler finde das ist von google das ist eben ein privates projekt von irgendjemand da ist
er der hat aber meine terminal breite excellent guckt euch das mal an das sieht richtig gut
aus oder achja wir können wir können übrigens das pippe please noch besser machen umso kleiner
man das terminal macht umso mehr pixel in anführungsstrichen hat man ja zur verfügung
kann man sowas sagen kann man sowas sagen wie breite oder so kann man sowas sagen wie
breite
das probieren wir jetzt noch mal aus hat zwar überhaupt nichts mit heute was ich sonst machen
ist jetzt breiter als sonst 200 oh jetzt muss das neu berechnen
warte mal kalms ich will ja rose rose will ich ja haben wobei eigentlich ok ich sehe
da jetzt ehrlich gesagt kein unterschied 400 rose 400 oh fuck leute guck mal volle volle
cpu auslastung für diff für gifs animieren guckt euch das mal an volle cpu auslastung
gif auf terminal berechnen braucht vier kerne zu 100 prozent
sehr effizient ja mal gucken ob es jetzt wenigstens funktioniert klar ich meine die hälfte
ist schon durch ja stream ihr bringt mich immer aufs auf tolle ideen ja
kann das auch raytrap bestimmt das ist nichts das ist nicht mehr rtx on da ist schon rtx
off oder wie heißt das neue von amd was auch in der playstation 5 drin ist das darf wieder
nicht rtx heißen weil sonst ist ja die anzeige direkt raus
könntest du mal ein paar geschichten aus deiner ausbildung berufsschule zählt ja du
musst mich nur auf die idee bringen welche der deadlift hatte übrigens vorhin geschrieben
hatte heute meine abschluss präsentation immerhin 92 von 100 punkten das ergebnis der
schriftlichen prüfung bekomme ich am 17 juni ja kratz kratz ich glaube ich hatte 95 wired
flex dafür war meine abschlussprüfung nicht so gut jetzt ist es da oben aber jetzt ist
er aber warum spacken von ks ok moment ich glaube mein terminal macht das nicht mit
oh mein terminal leckt mein terminal leckt leute
oder man nie mein terminal ist nicht hoch genug mein terminal ist nicht hoch genug wollen
wir mal machen wir mal rose nur 300 und jetzt muss er neu processen ich fasse es nicht
wie viel rose im terminal sind denn das keine ahnung wie viele zeilen passen die wollen
in das terminal rein 200 300 kein schimmer 180 meinste ok machen wir machen wir mal rose
160 ich habe echt kein kein schimmer wollte max gerade nachzählen ja man kann das ja
so ungefähr machen wenn es erst 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 da kannst du ungefähr sagen ok
wenn das 10 sind dann sind das so 100 ungefähr so bis da also konnten doch so 300 sein
mein threadrepper hat auch mal geschluckt ja ich mein gifs wie gesagt gifs zu processen
fürs terminal scheint eine äußerst komplexe angelegenheit zu sein die durchaus auch schon
mal 4 cpu kerne zu 100 prozent in beschlag nehmen kann ja das hängt ja von der schriftgröße
ab wie viel wie viel da rein passt ne also so passen ja definitiv weniger zeilen rein
wie so sei es logisch ne projekte die gifs stattdessen über die grafikkarte rendern
lassen ja das ist einfach da muss man nichts da muss man nicht viel machen für was meinst
du denn wie diese gifs hier gerendert werden wenn nicht über die grafikkarte der witz
ist ja gerade das im terminal läuft über den audioausgang richtig
es sagt immer noch zu da war mal 60 160 das lässt mir das lässt mir jetzt keine ruhe
das lässt mir jetzt keine er schreibt ich bin letztes jahr fertig geworden und hat meine
ausbildungsbedarf jetzt noch ein jahr gearbeitet ok ja wie gesagt ich habe auch noch eine weile
danach gearbeitet ok ok es nimmt gestalt an
also ist das doch wunderbar oder exquisite excellent so ist das perfekt so mag ich das
perfekte auflösung im terminal ja also irgendjemand hat gesagt ich soll noch mal was aus meiner
berufsschule und ausbildungszeit erzählen kann ich machen die sache ist bloß die da
muss er mich schon mal ein bisschen auf ideen bringen ansonsten so was mir so spontan einfällt
habe ich auch schon alles fünfmal erzählt du hast anfang der woche deinen job als admin
gekündigt ja kann man machen wenn es einem nicht gefällt vor allem es lag wahrscheinlich
an der firma gehe ich mal von aus wobei reine admin geschichten gibt es ja eh immer weniger
abgefühlt echt burn out und die themen haben mich nicht interessiert machen und techniker
ok verstehe ja das liegt auch ein bisschen an der jeweiligen firma natürlich wie sehr
die da ein einspannen und wie sehr der druck da von allen seiten ist dass man das mitnimmt
also wenn man morgens aufsteht und am liebsten quasi gar nicht aus der haustür gehen will
also mehr als man das sonst hat dann ist das ist das kein gutes zeichen ja
alles defops jetzt ja die richtig coolen leute sind full stack adidas andreas sagt heute
soll admin das machen wofür es früher eine ganze abteilung gab das ist teilweise wahr
und teilweise nicht also also eine sache wo was dran ist ist dass du heute als admin schon
je nachdem wie die infrastruktur aussieht alleine mehr machen kannst als früher durch die durch
ganze durch die ganze virtualisierungsgeschichte und jetzt in neueren zeiten auch container
geschichte und vielleicht sogar infrastruktur gar nicht mehr bei einem haus hat man als
admin weniger zu tun und es gibt auch vielmehr automatisierungsmöglichkeiten angefangen
von so oldschool sachen wie puppet jetzt ein bisschen neue ansible oder dann irgendwelche
cloud terraformen hast du nicht gesehen also man kann als admin schon man kann als admin
schon mehr machen allerdings kommt auch und das ist das was dagegen ist ein bisschen dagegen
spricht dazu gehört natürlich auch noch viel mehr drum herum jetzt was früher nicht
gegeben hat früher bist als admin mal ins rz hast geguckt ob der lüfter noch läuft
dann war ok so nach dem motto oder hast du die festplatte gewechselt wenn was ausmacht
heute musste erst mal das asher cli aufmachen und gucken welche kupanete spots du noch
starten musst dass die last ausgesagt hat übertrieben gesagt also es hat sich schon
ein bisschen geändert also heute machst du generell als admin ganz andere sachen als
früher es gibt auch noch so die ganz klassischen admin geschichten aber das ist auslaufmodell
ja acht terabyte huge die wahrsten das war das huge muss muss so sein aber klassische
admin geschichten sind schon ein bisschen am auflaufen auslaufen das ist entweder geht
das ein bisschen mehr in richtung defops heute bei entwickler geht es ja auch einmal in richtung
defops bisschen mehr richtung full stack dann ist big data an sich ist ja heute immer das
schlagwort heute ist das ja dann data science oder sonst was aber ganze ganze cloud und
google cloud asia cloud aws geschichten das ist heute noch mal ein ganz neues felt was
dazu gekommen ist was es früher gar nicht gegeben hat hoffentlich lernen die physis
das bald auch in der berufsschule da würde ich mich nicht darauf verlassen kennst du
noch den turnschuhe admin klar ich habe früher auch turnschuhe admin gemacht ich habe ich
bin jeden morgen ins rechenzentrum und bin einmal rund gelaufen und habe geguckt ob irgendwelche
wahnlichtchen irgendwo an sind naja wenn du jetzt als physi anfängst ist ja nichts schlimmes
als physi lernt man halt auch heute nicht mehr das was man als physi vor 15 jahren gelernt
hat wie gesagt klassisches wir sitzen vor irgendeinem rechner und tippen was in unsere
konsole ein ist halt zum größteil nicht mehr klar gibt es noch gibt es auch klassische
administrations operating sonst was stellen weil es ja noch viele firmen gibt die server
bei sich im rechenzentrum stehen haben und ein paar in haus sachen betreiben also weggehen
wird das wahrscheinlich nie komplett aber es verlagert sich und wenn wir da als bank
schon anfangen mit azure und cloud da können davon ausgehen wir sind in der regel einer
der naja nicht unbedingt mal ganz vorne mit dabei und außerdem gibt es ja ab diesem
jahr glaube neue neue fachinformatiker fachrichtung wo wo wo ich mich frage wo wo ich naja nicht
so genau weiß ob die überhaupt irgendjemand anbietet easy killer es kommt drauf an also
der easy killer sagt ich glaube die meisten kleinen und mittelständischen unternehmen
haben noch sehr viel klassisches administrieren nur die großen unternehmen mit viel kohle
machen das mit defops und so ja es kommt drauf an wenn es irgendwas alteingesessenes ist
also wenn es jetzt irgendwie eine autowerkstatt ist oder sowas die werden ihre zwei computer
die sie da stehen haben um rechnung zu drucken und um sachen zu bestellen nicht irgendwie
krasses cloud computing in azure machen jetzt und dass sie da mal irgendwann haben der ab
und zu mal auf den rechner drauf guckt der vielleicht noch mehrere andere werkstätten
am tag betreut gut das das wird wahrscheinlich bleiben das wird sich in zukunft nicht nicht
großartig ändern aber umso neuer das ganze wird umso fitter sind sowohl halt auch die
die die die mitarbeiter vor allem der chef was das angeht und wenn du mal in den bereich
guckst wenn du jetzt neuere unternehmen hast die sich halt auch mit technik beschäftigen
wird unter anderem verkaufen klar und da machen die da schon so also so dieses diese diese
ganz klassische geschichte wir haben 2 3 racks im keller stehen ist immer weniger und gerade
wenn du kleiner bist könntest du auch genau in das rein also genau dort reinfallen wo
sich das richtig lohnt wenn du keinen eigenen serverraum oder keinen eigenen standort dafür
brauchst ich mein grad in frankfurt oder es ist ja egal frankfurt münchen ist überall
teuer kostet es halt auch richtig geld je nachdem was du da haben willst oder du musst
ein haus umbauen mussten muss den keller erweitern lassen was auch immer wenn du dir keine location
so mieten willst aber ihr seid mit 10.000 mitarbeiter ja auch nicht klein und wenn es
halt da so festgefahren ist aber das wird kommen das wird nicht mal lange dauern da
wird der größte teil der unternehmen entweder weg vom fenster sein oder halb oder halbwegs
modern ich habe letztens einen netten artikel drüber gelesen wo sich einer drüber ausgelassen
hat woher also warum es in deutschland neuerdings so viele ich nenne was man start ups gibt
und so so viele technikunternehmen die auf einmal so dick im geschäft sind und er hat
gesagt es liegt daran weil die ganzen alten richtig großen unternehmen das die letzten
zehn jahre verpennt haben das heißt die machen jetzt gar nicht super krass neues zeug die
helfen einfach den alten mal ein bisschen anschluss zu halten man kann natürlich auch
intern sachen mit muss ja nicht gleich kubernetes sein ein bisschen moderner machen was aber
nicht so so prinzipien wie automatisierte builds leute die sowohl anwendung als auch
server als auch entwicklungsprozess im blick haben geben sollte das hat ja mit ob man einen
standort hat oder nicht wenig zu tun klipper sagt er fragt sich was nach kubernetes kommt
irgendwie einen neuen hype dem alle nachrennen wie ich habe es ja schon oft im stream gesagt
nicht unbedingt der neueste hype ist immer für das jeweilige projekt das beste also
vielleicht vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern vor ein paar jahren da war es
ja voll im trend dass man da war es ja voll voll im ich glaube mein mein scrollback buffer
ist ein bisschen pro jetzt gerade wegen dem vielen gifs und da war es ja voll im trend
dass man sachen in mongo db node js macht so vor fünf jahren oder so oder noch länger
noch ein bisschen länger als das aufgekommen ist alles node js mongo db ohne dass sich
irgendjemand mal gedanken darüber gemacht hat ist das was wir programmieren überhaupt
sinnvoll in der no sql ist es überhaupt sinnvoll das mit node js zu machen nein wir machen
einfach mongo db node js ja also solchen hype sachen nachzurennen ist dämlich also
es ist auch total beknackt zu sagen ok wir sind eine kleine klitsche mit drei desktops
und keine ahnung nimm technology nass und machen auch sonst mit technik nix sondern
wir keine ahnung was gibt es denn heute noch großartig was mit technik gar nichts zu tun
hat ja wir machen fußboden reinigung und und drucken drucken nur unsere rechnung über
die rechner aus und haben irgendwie ein kleines archiv bei uns drauf und auf dropbox gesüngt
oder was auch immer die müssen natürlich jetzt nicht anfangen mit wir haben jetzt
unseren geilen kubernetes cluster in aws und machen jetzt unsere rechner rechnungsgenerierung
über über kubernetes dass er schwach sind aber was die machen können und was die auf
jeden fall machen werden wenn es einen guten anbieter ist wenn es einen guten anbieter
gibt die werden sich nicht mehr selbst darum kümmern weil die wollen das machen und am
meisten zeit für haben womit sie geld machen und wo sie am besten sind nämlich fußboden
reinigung und wenn es in cloud service gibt der quasi genau für sie das richtige anbietet
also was auch immer die brauchen vom rechnungs rechnungs erstellen bis zum einsatzkräfte
planen bis zu sonst was dann werden die das machen und werden ihre lokale infrastruktur
abschaffen über kurz oder lang die werden auch blöd wenn ich was fährst du eigentlich
für ein auto
der ist sowas von agile alter huge agile ist ja also meiner sieht nicht mehr so gut
aus ja das ist ja ein tauf tauf meine hat zum beispiel hier eine beule das ist ja noch
ein tauf richtig aber die farbe stimmt schon mal die farbe stimmt schon mal und auch gg
gg gg thanks fährt selten sebaro exzellente wahl ja das ist auch das ist das ist also
ich habe es nicht umsonst nach 2001 gesucht das ding ist auch 2001 also das ist kurz kurz
vom monat gs daniel wohl kann sein wahrscheinlich gibt für alles irgendwelche abkürzung max
ließte ich das mal durch ok ja der hat recht der hat vollkommen recht bill gates ist big
brain kommt mal das hat bill gates angeblich gesagt er hat gesagt er wird immer die immer
einen faulen eine faule person aussuchen um eine schwierige aufgabe zu erledigen weil
die faule person was findet wie man das einfach macht exakt das habe ich auch schon 50.000
mal erzählen genauso ist es das würde ich als chef auch machen was runterscrollen wohin
dann hacker scripts hacker scripts 28.000 ok 38.000 was soll das sein
das skript zum kaffee machen oder was den text oh nee das wird zu lang das wird zu lang
zu big brain heute abend bei telnet mit kaffee maschine verbunden ja ich würde sich wundern
wenn das mit unseren kaffee maschinen sogar funktioniert man die haben einen touch haben
einen großen led touch screen und irgendein irgendein rs 232 debug port an der side die
haben bestimmt auch telnet anschluss gab es über den ich sogar ein heiße artikel kann
schon sein ich kann auch nicht alle ich weiß nicht von welcher marke keine ahnung habe
ich ja nie so genau angeguckt weil ich trinkein kaffee ich bin also nie an der kaffeemaschine
aus dem habe ich eh die ganze zeit home office gerade kann man die auf discord mal schreiben
bezüglich fisi ausbildung auf discord also kannst auf discord schreiben mit anderen aber
wenn du irgendwas wissen willst kannst du mich im stream fragen außer es ist so secret unwichtig
dass du es hier nicht verraten kannst aber dann weiß ich auch nicht ob ich dir dabei
helfen kann wie funktioniert kubanetes ungefähr na gut also wie das intern funktioniert habe
ich ehrlich gesagt kein plast und schimmer ich kann dir sagen was es ist kubanetes ist
ein container nennt man das manager orchestrator heißt das glaube ich offiziell also wenn du
unterschiedliche container hast mit docker so die klassische variante ja da hast ja ein
hardcoded docker file da steht drinne was der container machen soll was natürlich schwierig
ist so mit mit der klassischen container geschichte oder sei es jetzt mit docker oder mit irgendwas
anderem doch kein synonym jetzt für linux container ja und da sind manche sachen sind
einfach ja zum beispiel reproduzierbare bild sind relativ einfach und es hat sich jetzt
dazu eingebürgert dass ja viele leute auch angefangen haben das quasi live systeme damit
zu betreiben also die anwendung in dem container auf irgendwelche produktiv live system haben
das laufen lassen so da hast du ja zwar die vorteile von die anwendung ist einfacher zu
deployen weil die beispielsweise alle libraries als abhängigkeit mitbringt und so was aber
du hast einen nachteil und den hast du quasi von der hardware geerbt im endeffekt oder
von vms also sprich wenn du jetzt fünf container von hand gestartet hast aber dann service
ist nicht ausgelastet dann laufen weiterhin fünf container und vielleicht auch auf zwei
verschiedenen drei verschiedene artverkästen oder fünf verschiedene artverkästen oder
umgedrehter fall also sprich wenn der service nicht ausgelassen ist drehen die däumchen
umgedrehter fall wenn irgendwie keine ahnung bill gates dich retweetet und auf einmal 350.000
user auf deinen service drauf wollen dann ist es reicht das nicht so und mit so einem orchestrierungstool
wie krupa netis zum beispiel ist es halt ziemlich einfach das ganze zu scaleen wie man so schön
das scaling ist oder das das big brain wort dafür da kannst du zum beispiel so was machen
dass du wenn es auf den load balenzen mehr last gibt weil mehr user drauf zugreifen du
im hintergrund noch auf was ist ich das drei verschiedene backendsysteme und die machen
alles mögliche und dort wo noch platz ist wird dann automatisch ein weiterer anwendungscontainer
gestartet dass die user last abgefangen wird und solche sachen ist halt sehr schön wenn
du da so ein management engine hast also eigentlich ist krupa netis und container management orchestrierungs
engine gibt ein paar andere es gab noch mesos glaube ich wie das hieß mesos gab es noch
fliet ne visas swarm swarm gab es auch mal aber das ist ja vorbei jetzt ist es nicht mesos apache
genau das gibt es auch noch das so bissl die die die alternative gewesen allerdings man muss halt
sagen krupa netis hat sich komplett durchgesetzt also es gibt eigentlich nichts vergleichbares vom
verbreitungsgrad und vom bekanntheitsgrad her aktuell wie krupa wie krupa netis das ist so ein
bisschen wie bereiencontainern docker es gibt 20.000 verschiedene möglichkeiten linuxcontainer zu
starten weil die linuxcontainer geschichte ist ja nichts was docker oder krupa netis machen würde
das ist im linuxkernel drin sowohl docker als auch krupa netis ist ja quasi nur ein frontend dafür
und docker ist halt auch so synonym für alle möglichen linuxcontainer mittlerweile obwohl
es eigentlich letztendlich auch nur ein bisschen kommando zeilen tool mit magic zum einfachen
handeln von container ist ja ich hoffe ich habe das jetzt halbwegs verständlich erklärt also ich
bin nicht der über krupa netis guru oder so ne also die normalen sachen kriege ich damit hin
diese ein nachteil an dieser technik ist es ist schwierig selbst sich beizubringen das
liegt daran dass das zeug nicht natürlich in umgebungen vorkommt wo man übt also wenn
jetzt zum beispiel einer sagt okay ich will mal irgendwas ausprobieren oftmals kommt es daher
weil er sich überlegt hat okay ich will daheim ein bisschen haus heim automatisierung machen oder
so ja dann beschäftigt er sich mit unterschiedlichen wireless protokollen mit unterschiedlichen
lösungen die es da gibt und sonst was da lernt man auch viel was man auf der arbeit gebrauchen
kann immer krupa netis ist was das trifft man jetzt im heimbereich nicht an man kann das machen ja
es gibt mini cube oder wie das heißt oder wie ist das andere k gibt ein paar es gibt ein paar
einstiegshilfen aber letztendlich du kannst dir daheim zwar in den rest in den raspberry
pie krupa netis cluster installieren mit zwei oder drei stück es ist aber reine spielerei also
wirst es nicht daheim für was sinnvolles verwenden nur klar es ist ohne probleme ja cube ctl kann
sein ist das nicht mini cube doch genau das meine ich das meine ich man kann das daheim
ausprobieren das ist gar kein problem du kannst den raspberry holen mit mir ich glaube mini cube
ist im prinzip auch nur in so ein installations tool oder weiß ich ob es in installations kript ist
genau auch relativ beliebt das ist quasi einen krupa netis manager für krupa netis container
manager so und das macht mit vr mit krupa netis läuft halt lokal so das ist halt für leute die
bock haben deshalb zu installieren das problem dabei ist nur du kannst das ohne probleme lokal
installieren du kannst ja auch wenn ein bisschen mit ausfallsicherheit oder container migration
oder was auch immer wenn ich damit ein bisschen beschäftigen willst das übrigens wie nennt sich
das das heißt ja nicht migration wie heißt das krupa netis ich sage immer verschieben dazu aber
verschieben ist nicht das richtige wort so und man kann man kann sich das natürlich ohne probleme
daheim hinstellen aber die meisten leute werden es halt nicht benötigen das nicht und kaum also
keiner braucht daheim krupa netis das wäre eine reine installation zum üben klar geht funktioniert
aber das schöne ist halt oftmals an projekten die man daheim macht für sich selbst man lernt
dabei viel was man halt auf der arbeit gebrauchen kann sei es wenn man irgendwas programmiert sei
es wenn man irgendwas aufsetzt ausprobiert automatisiert da lernt man immer sachen die
man auch auf der arbeit brauchen kann aber krupa netis musste die halt quasi explizit zu
lernzwecken daheim aufsetzen es hat finde ich wenig sinn im heim im heimbereich ja ich weiß
es gibt leute die schwören da total drauf ich habe letztens auch wieder eingesehen auf dem
home assistant subreddit der erzählt hat wie er da seine sein raspberry pi container flotte
am start hat ganz ehrlich ich halte das für nicht sinnvoll daheim das liegt zum größten
an dem grund weil das managen von so einem krupa netis cluster viel overhead und und viel
fehler anfälligkeit in was sonst ein einfaches reinbringt also sprich wenn ich mich jetzt
hinsetze daheim und installiere mir was weiß ich nen file server ich installiere mir einfach
den samba auf einem ob ich mache mir den lesbian und ist dann immer ein samba drauf und steckt
eine externe festplatte dran und macht fileserver dann ist das einfach so wenn ich das ganze jetzt
auf krupa netis machen will ist das unendlich da unendlich nicht aber halt unglaublich viel
komplizierter deutlich fehler anfälliger auch noch dazu und davon haben du es auch nicht viel
das heißt warum sollte man das wirklich machen das wäre rein zum üben und rein zum üben für
was was man auf der arbeit braucht haben halt inklusive mir viele leute nicht allzu viel
motivation ja ich übe also ich mache ganz gerne sachen daheim die mir daheim auch was bringen
wo es dann auch was für die arbeit bringt aber rein sachen quasi lernen die ich nicht daheim
brauche und sogar für kontraproduktiv daheim brauche damit ich auf der arbeit besser kann
da darf man das dafür mal chef bezahlen docker os x das haben wir ausprobiert ja und auch viel
overhead auf dem haus selbst naja also so ein container overhead hält sich eigentlich in
grenzen und nachdem krupa netis ja nur ein bisschen management zeug drumherum ist kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das wahnsinnig viel overhead erzeugt also muss ja mal sagen dass einen
linux container also einen prozess den ich im linux container starte oder einen prozess den
ich auf dem linux host starte fundamental das gleiche ist beides ist ein stink normaler linux
also ganz normaler prozess unter linux der einzige unterschied ist dass wenn man das in
ein in einem container starten ist eigentlich das vollkommen falsche wort du startest den prozess
auf dem host kernel wie jeden normalen prozess also in dem aus der sich so wirklich ein container
der da drumherum ist es gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht der unterschied ist dass zwischen den
system api zwischen manchen system api und den prozess bei container noch so eine übersetzung
schicht dazwischen ist also zum beispiel für hostname zum beispiel für für netzwerk für
irgendwelche berechtigungsgeschichten für fallsystem zugriff und solche geschichten also sprich
das nach wie vor ein stink normaler prozess der auf dem host kernel läuft aber der hat
halt vielleicht gewisse einschränkungen so und das was im linux kernel drinne ist was das macht
heißt auch nicht container oder so das läuft zwar alles letztendlich unter lxc linux container aber
das sind namespaces und cgroups nennt sich das im linux kernel also nix von wegen container
container gibt es in der art und weise gar nicht irgendjemand ist auf die glorreiche idee
genommen und gekommen und hat es halt linux container genannt aber eigentlich sind es
namespaces und cgroups im linux kernel was diese verwendung als container gestartet und das ist
auch nicht das einzige also unter bsd gibt es mit jails was relativ ähnliches und es ist auch nicht
das erste was es unter linux in der art und weise gab es gab ich habe jetzt auch vergessen
wie das heißt es gab unter linux vorher schon ein paar ähnliche sachen aber dank docker und
das ist auch der grund warum das war zu verbreitet dank docker ging halt diese linux container
geschichte mit namespaces und cgroups durch die decke weil docker das halt sehr einfach
gemacht hat und intuitiv zu benutzen so
ehrenfreund fragt ich mache mal kurz die frage auf habe bei mir auf einem raspberry pi p ist
hier wieder spackt hier wieder der darkreader rum okay ich habe mir aber ich habe bei mir auf dem
raspberry pi ein piehall laufen kann ich parallel noch einen webserver draufsetzen ja warum nicht
piehall lässt halt alle möglichen scripts laufen die das ding halt vorkonfigurieren für den dns
filter oder für den dns server mit blacklists unter der haube ist es ein ganz normales debian
also du kannst da ohne probleme jeden x beliebigen webserver darauf installieren den lustig bist
ich würde den leiter ttpd auch in ruhe lassen also ich würde nichts von dem anfassen was piehall
verwendet das ist dann halt ein bisschen kontraproduktiv weil er den vielleicht das
klar kaputt macht aber du kannst ohne probleme dich da per ssh drauf einloggen und einen anderen
webserver installieren es ist absolut kein problem das ist ganz normales debian was drunter ist das
ist beispielsweise ein guter einsatzzweck für für container oder vms sowas wie piehall also
wenn ich bin angenommen ich hätte den raspberry pie den ich als piehall verwenden will oder
piehall oder wie immer das genau ausspricht es klingt auf jeden fall immer irgendwie
unanständig egal welche betonung ich würde das anders machen ich würde mir also wenn ich den
raspberry pie hätte ich wüsste dass ich den piehall drauf installieren will und ich wüsste
auch dass ich ihn anderweitig verwenden will ich würde da würde ich das anders machen da würde
ich den raspberry pie installieren mit dem ganz normalen raspbian und dann würde ich das piehall
als container beziehungsweise gibt es eigentlich ein fertiges docker piehall ich würde es nämlich
gar nicht auf dem docker laufen lassen ok guck mal gibt es gibt sogar schon fix und fertig na dann
würde ich das machen genau also ich würde das piehall auf dem container laufen lassen ich hätte
gesagt am lxd container weil es halt auch ein komplettes filesystem mit dabei hat aber wenn
es ein offizielles docker image gibt von piehall würde ich das verwenden dann lässt du nämlich
das piehall im docker container laufen und auf dem host kannst du machen was du willst
und den webserver kannst du auch in docker laufen lassen aber wenn du dann richtig big brain bist
dann machst du noch ein reverse proxy davor der für dich das handling von ssl-zertifikaten macht
falls du eine falls du eine domain hast die da drauf verwendest das ist das ist dann wirklich
die pro variante ja und man kann ja auch externe domains intern verwenden das ist ja kein problem
also ich habe ja auch eine domain ich zeige euch mal meinen staubsauger noch mal kurz also das hier
ist ja die das webinterface von meinem staubsauger und ihr seht ihr hier oben die domain die kann
ich intern verwenden weil ich die einfach auf einem dns eingetragen habe ja also die domain
gehört mir also um genau zu sein die gehört nicht mir die domain gehört glaube ich einem
peter wubblors oder so ich habe mich damit in einem fake angemeldet peter peter k punkt wubblors
oder so das hat den domain man darf das eigentlich nicht ja aber das hat den domain registran nicht
die bohne gejuckt weil warum sollte es ihn auch hier er kriegt er geld für und das habe ich
bei mir so gemacht dass die domains die ich für also ich muss jetzt mal überlegen was ich ob ich
euch das zeigen glaube ich kann ich kann die kamera web die die kamera überwachungs webseite
gerade nicht aufmachen so zumindest die haben gültige die haben gültige ssl zertifikate die
meisten sachen unter der domain und das funktioniert folgendermaßen jetzt mal krasse krasse hyper
paint skills aber das funktioniert jetzt also oder nee wir machen keine paint skills wir sind viel
wir sind viel besser wir machen tru iow tru iow device new diagram excellent das sieht damit
dag sieb voll eklig aus alter ja ist schon besser so und was wir da haben wir haben hier ein server
so ja mit der kiste das kann raspberry pi oder was auch immer oder sonst was sein vollkommen
egal das ist die das ist die hardware kiste die machen wir noch fetter die steht hier rum da drauf
ach komm wir machen das anders das hier ist die hardware kiste so und da drinnen laufen
guck mal wie das hier macht da drin läuft zum beispiel ein home assistant läuft da drin da
läuft drinnen ein next cloud da läuft was habe ich wo habe ich noch vor wo habe ich noch mein
mein git git web frontend gedöns so reicht jetzt erst mal als beispiel so das läuft das läuft da
drauf jeweils in einem docker container und davor ist ein weiterer docker container
über proxy mit ich kann das ding nicht richtig schreiben irgendwie so schreibt man das glaube
ich dass so ein ikea wort ich habe sogar richtig geschrieben als reverse proxy so und was das
ding macht ops kann man das jetzt kleiner machen oder wie kann man das kleiner machen und
what the fuck will das einfach kleiner machen ok big brain mit schiff nehmen mit schiff geht's nicht schiff mag nicht arrange
voll durch die brust ins orgel so und der hier managt die ganzen domains und der managt auch
die zertifikate über letzten kript kennst du camp ja kenne ich allerdings administriere ich
die nicht und das ding geht dann einmal alle drei monate glaube ich zu letzten kript letzten kript
und aktualisiert für meine ganzen domains die kann man das so machen
aktualisiert das ist übrigens falsch rum ich will einen feil haben der in die andere
richtung geht das ding aktualisiert dann einmal alle drei monate die zertifikate für die dienste
die dahinter laufen ein camps in load balancer camps in load balancer
so ich glaube er kennt was ich weiß ich weiß so das ist das ist das ist eine echt praktische
lösung weil du kannst man könnte man kann hier noch einen noch einen container laufen lassen
den dinger auch immer aktualisiert also ich habe es jetzt so eingestellt dass der immer
auf die aktuelle major version die ich die also nächst laut major version aktualisiere ich von
hand allerdings die jeweils aktuelle meiner version macht er immer automatisch bei homos sind
ähnlich hier auch und davor werden halt zertifikate aktualisiert alle drei monate das heißt die
dinger haben immer automatisch aktuelle zertifikate das ist ein sehr praktisches setup das updated
sich zum teil automatisch was man wo man schon mal keine arbeit mit hat und man hat immer top
aktuelle gültige ssl zertifikate was auch sehr praktisch ist und sogar wenn man sachen auf einem
handy verwenden möchte also auf auf dem iphone oder android sogar erforderlich für viele sachen
dass sie ein gültiges ssl zertifikate haben das heißt das ist eine sache ich weiß nicht wer es
im chat geschrieben hat so so einen aufbau würde ich mal üben da da sind viele technologien dabei
die einem auch in zukunft was bringen und das ist und das ist auch ein setup was ich so vielleicht
jetzt nicht mit home assistant und nextcloud was man aber auch so ähnlich im professionellen
umfeld sieht dass du irgendwelche services hast ein reverse proxy davor wenn du das nach außen
anbietest und das update mit let's encrypt ist was was im professionellen umfeld finde ich viel
zu wenig gemacht wird es spuckt ja immer noch in den köpfen der leuten rum dass quasi nur
teure ssl zertifikate gute ssl zertifikate sind was natürlich kompletter blödsinn ist kannst du
das auf dem discord speichern ne aber das wort ist ja da das könntest du ja mal im stream machen
wäre interessant ja das war mal was bei pile mit irgendwie kann und reverse proxy da muss ich nur
meine na wie heißen sie na wie heißen sie noch mal die die cdn detection machen cloudflare genau
da muss ich doch gucken wie ich meine cloudflare credentials verstecke für die domain wenn du
das machst gebe ich dir eins ab ich verkaufe keine subs und streaminhalte aber wahrscheinlich
mache ich das weil das ein interessantes thema ist das kann man echt mal ausprobieren das finde
ich jetzt gut dass man wahrscheinlich am wochenende da installieren uns ein aktuelles lesbian drauf
machen mal zwei drei container und dann schaue ich mal wie ich meine meine credentials verstecke
für meine cloudflare domain und dann richten wir das mal irgendwie ein
ja so sieht es aus es gab nur jede menge andere fragen habe ich hier gerade gesehen
könntest du noch mal eine komplette testumgebung auf von was
wie löst du denn intern dein dns gedöns auf mit einem intern dns aber
man kann auch bei cloudflare mit tokens welche ip limitierung erarbeiten echt ich hatte das
problem ich habe das probiert und zum damaligen zeitpunkt hat das traffic cloudflare plugin also
was das halt das aktuelle sie dem hintergrund macht hat das nur mit dem full access tauchen
unterstützt vielleicht geht das mittlerweile auch was anderes weil dann wäre es nicht das
problem dann könnte ich meinen tauchen liegen und ich könnte es tauchen danach einfach wieder
rückgängig machen gut ist easy as facke würde ich dazu sagen so achso welchen dns ich benutze
also ich verwende meistens wenn ich irgendein dns benutzen muss weil ich irgendwie special
sachen machen muss dns mask das ganz praktisch das ding ist total simpel kann fast alles und
ist relativ einfach zu verwenden allerdings in in dem fall von mir daheim mache ich ganz
billig ich verwende den dns der in meinen mikrotik router drinne ist ich bin ja mittlerweile
auch auf dem trip dass ich so wenig wie möglich selber mache und damit meine ich halt von den
sachen die ich selber host beziehungsweise intern verwende so so wenig wie möglich selbst aufsetze
ihr kennt ja meine meine meine 4h e-server kiste ja das habe ich das ja jetzt wieder mit
total viele geguckt die 4h e-server kiste die ist mittlerweile aus und macht nichts mehr das
ist alles auf kleinere geräte ausgelagert beziehungsweise manche sagen gibt es auch gar
nicht mehr verbraucht viel weniger strom und gibt kein single point of failure mehr
und deswegen verwende ich mein wer immer das gerade gefragt hat sachen sack falde verwende
ich den dns server auf meinem mikrotik router und trag die paar hosten haben die ich intern
verwende das sind wir keine ahnung 8 9 10 stück hardcoded in meinen mikrotik router dns ein und gut
ist und das steht zumindest schon in docks sollte support sein ok dann ist gut also wie gesagt als
ich das eingerichtet habe bei mir das ist jetzt aber auch schon bestimmt ein jahr her konnte
dass das noch nicht da musste da ging es nur mit der mit der alten api token variante wurde
ist quasi irgendwie kein token was laber ich nur mit der mit den credentials also sprich man musste
man musste man musste wirklich credentials hinterlegen dass es funktioniert hat und die
will ich ja nicht unbedingt liegen für cloudflare und streaken verwendet so eine fritz box oder die
billige unity media box beides leider noch beides es ist ja bei mir so ganz vorne habe ich die unity
media connect box dahinter habe ich eine billige fritz box die die billigste fritz box die es
gibt kann ich 60 euro oder so also die die alle ein die die einsteigerigste einsteiger fritz box
hängen die macht woib und deckt weil woib und deckt sachen sind die man nicht selber machen will
und einem anderen port von der unity media box hängt mein mikrotik router der alles andere macht
was der große vorteil ist dass unity media zwar zugriff auf die unity media box hat aber spätestens
an meiner mikrotik router ist schluss also die domain hast du dir nur gekauft damit
letztendlich dir auch zertifikate geben kann ja also eigentlich habe ich mir die domain gekappt
habe ich mir die zwei domains gekauft also wir machen das dann mit poggers poggers xy z gehört
mir beide bei auch oder auch nicht oder was progas progas xy z war es glaube ich warte mal
ich muss mal grad hu is machen hu is progas xy z hab ich die vielleicht habe ich die domain nicht ver- was?
es gibt kein hu is oks hu is progas xy z ja porkband das ok progas habe ich mir gekauft nicht poggers
so und guckt mal wem die domain gehört die rücken das gar nicht mal raus auf anfrage also die domain
gehört irgendwie einem peter k wubbler oder so also für die domain wenn wir das machen weil
die verwende ich sonst nix so wozu hast du da noch einen mikrotik router dahinter ja also ich
habe das setup so schon ziemlich lange muss ich sagen auch schon zu telekom zeiten ich habe immer
hinter dem provider modem schrägstich router was dahinter weil der provider zugriff auf das modem
hatten damit theoretisch also auf den router hatten damit theoretisch auf alles was dran
angestöpselt ist oder habe ich keinen bock drauf da kommt noch was dahinter wo der provider garantiert
kein zugriff drauf hatten gut ist ja und natürlich auch unter anderem wegen sowas ist die musik auf
einmal doppelt so laut geworden ja zum beispiel auch sowas weil die ganzen wlan also das china
wlan das china geräte wlan das streaming wlan und das normale tablet smartphone wlan da sind
auch noch unterschiedliche wlan drunter das beispielsweise das china wlan auch nirgends
wohin darf ja also ja ich verwende auch ein paar features die die fritzbox so nicht kann man kann
so immer wieder betonen die fritzbox an sich ist echt kein guter router also was die was was die
fritzbox an an routing funktionen hat ist für den arsch allerdings ist die fritzbox ein super
multifunktionsgerät es beide ich habe keine ahnung was eine tr69 anfrage ist ich habe
keine ahnung was das ist also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass in irgendeiner art und
weise unity media zugriff über was auch immer tr69 ist auf meinen mikrotik router hat
doch nein
die telekom kann deine geräte im heimnetz sehen die telekom kann auch nur die geräte
sehen die direkt dort dran angeschlossen sind meine geräte sind ja gar nicht an der fritz an
der unity media box angeschlossen an der unity media box sind zwei geräte angeschlossen eine
fritzbox für deckt und woib und mein mikrotik router alles andere intern bei mir ist hinter
dem mikrotik router da sehen die bei unity media gar nichts das einzige was sie sehen ist die
absender ip vom mikrotik router und eingehend ist auf dem mikrotik router eh nix erlaubt ist
wie bei einem iphone das melden sie immer bei apple das ist ja auch was anderes das iphone
geht von innen nach außen auf irgendeine auf irgendeine domain von apple oder auf
irgendeinen haus nahm von apple und connect sich davon innen nach außen ist ja auch kein
problem aber wir reden hier von außen nach innen und da wird mein mikrotik router garantiert nicht
sich irgendwo bei unity media melden warum sollte es das auch machen das ist ein mikrotik router das
hat mit unity media nichts zu tun und eingehen ist da eh nix erlaubt und insofern
ja wie gesagt das ist nicht egal wie soll wie soll das wie soll das denn überhaupt funktionieren
mein
mein mikrotik root ok ok ich so mikrotik ich hab keiner was tr69 ist so scheint fast
irgendwie ein bisschen obskures zu sein ja das ist irgendwas was man was man einrichten muss
auf diese auf dem mikrotik ding also ich habe nicht aktiv tr69 nach außen gesperrt aber es
wäre sehr merkwürdig wenn das irgendwie vorkonfiguriert an random adressen die es
gar nicht gibt was schickt aber hier was ist die fault das ist das ist das scheint
eine grisere act zu sein das überhaupt einzurichten ist es tr 069
ja also sollte das an sein und also gehen wir mal von dem theoretischen fall da wäre
irgendwas eingeschaltet womit und der router würde irgendwie eine anfrage schicken eine default ip
und unity media würde dann diese default ip an der connect box anlegen und dort dann
irgendeine router firmware hochladen falls das geht ohne alles ja und das dann kann das kann
das doch eine lücke sein aber das ist mir neu und ich habe jetzt dazu nichts gesehen und ich
würde es wundern wenn er das die fault mäßig macht aber das dann verstehe verstehe ich was
du meinst ja dann verstehe ich was du meinst aber das wird mich wundern wenn das standard
mäßig an ist vor allem wenn man den router in im rein so klein mode halt oder oder cascaded
irgendwie dahinter also man kann es ja im setup anklicken als was man den betreiben will und
ich habe das als ganz normal internet gateway zeug glaubt nicht dass das an ist ja aber
das ist okay das ist auf jeden fall nicht schlecht zu wissen auch wenn es mich sehr wundern würde
wenn das da irgendwie an ist aber man lernt ja nicht aus so was haben wir sonst noch
hast du auf deiner fritzbox auch noch so ein rufnummern importiert damit dich keine betrüge an
wieso können dürfen sie da überhaupt drauf schauen ja weil es ihre hardware ist das heißt
selbst wenn sie es nicht dürften könnten sie es auf jeden fall also aber wie gesagt
hier der mikrotik router kann das anscheinend haben wir gerade gesehen aber es wäre sehr
merkwürdig wenn das in der default konfig irgendwie so eingerichtet wäre dass das dass
irgendwas macht ja und ich sehe es auch gerade man sieht hier dass es beim mikrotik nicht
der fall ist weil hier steht when the packages install first available das heißt dass das
funktioniert muss man sogar noch ein zusatz package installieren auf dem mikrotik router
und das habe ich auf jeden fall nicht gemacht das zusatz package dafür zu installieren
das heißt das kann gar nichts senden so was haben wir denn sonst noch hier für sachen
wie gesagt wieso können wir dürfen sie das machen warum sie dürfen also ich könnte
mir vorstellen sie dürfen das eigentlich nicht da irgendwie zu gucken was im netzwerk
los ist bei dir aber nachdem sie zu wachungsarbeiten sich auf den router connecten können müssen
können sie es auch sehen ob sie es machen weiß ich nicht aber sie können das und dass
es möglich ist ist ja schon insofern klar das ist ein gerät vom hersteller das heißt
im zweifelsfall weißt du nicht dass es geht und es geht das ist auch der grund warum ich
da immer noch eine extra box dahinter hängen habe und spätestens an meinem mikrotik router
ist halt schluss aus sicht der unity media connect box kannst du mir eine gute ms zertifizierung
empfehlen oh nö mach ne azure zertifikat wie kann ich ein spezifisches linux kernel header
installieren indem du an a-a machst je nachdem ob du debian oder sonst wo bist dir die kernel
version raus suchst und dann in deinem paket manager nach kernel header für die version
suchst und du kannst es auch kürzer ab machen und das automatisch einsetzen lassen in dein
suchtbefehl aber ne was muss man minus er ne doch minus er ist es glaube ich das kann
sie machen aber die meisten paket manager sind mittlerweile so clever wenn du das ist
dann da ist linux kernel header ist ein meta package das heißt wenn du einfach linux
kernel header installierst dann installiert er automatisch das was du für ein kernel
auch laufen hast wohl eher die disconnect box ja unity media beziehungsweise jetzt ja
voter phone wobei ich sagen muss ey in letzter zeit ne kann man nicht meckern funktioniert
der kram echt ganz gut wahrscheinlich ich also ich könnte immer noch wetten das war
eben ein social media typ der geantwortet hat auf twitter
achja genau da wollte ich was zu sagen also du hast die domain nur gekauft damit letzter
enkript zertifikate geben kann halbe halbe einmal weil es so schöne kurze domain ist
und zweitens weil es halt mit gültigen domains ziemlich easy ist mit letzter enkript dns
challenge und fertig klar man kann auch so was wie dac dns verwenden
aber da ist irgendwas eklig zu merken das ja das ist so schon ganz gut wie gesagt das
probieren wir mal das probieren wir am wochenende im stream aus das ist eine gute idee gewesen
ja mit bein bein bin ich persönlich ein bisschen auf kriegsfuß ich finde das ding unnötig
konfus und kompliziert aber bein ist halt der klassiker also wenn man wenn man sich
nicht sicher ist was man für sau rein mit dns anstellen möchte dann nimmt man bein
weil man kann sich sicher sein dass jede noch so erdenkliche kacke mit bein funktioniert
egal wie wir es ist mit bein funktioniert kann man das auch mit nx machen klar natürlich
das kannst du mit alle möglichen machen letztendlich ist er dem dem reverse proxy egal was dahinter
läuft ja du kannst nx auch als reverse proxy verwenden sogar ziemlich gut habe ich auch
eine weile laufen gab bei mir und ich bilde mir sogar ein ich glaube unten auf dem raspberry
ist es sogar noch so ist auch kein problem allerdings soweit ich weiß kann durchaus
sein dass ich da falsch liege gibt es kein nx plugin irgendwie was für dich letztendlich
automatisch macht was nicht so sehr das problem ist weil du nx einfach ein verzeichnis sagen
kannst wo es seine zertifikate sucht und dann musst du dein zertbot automatisch laufen
lassen und das mit den zertifikaten machen lassen ja das ist auch kein ding das ist
ein schritt mehr manuell und wahrscheinlich musste danach nx reloaden wohlgemerkt reloaden
nicht restarten der unterschied ist beim reloaden liest der config files und keys neu ein und
beim restart starte den dienst neu nx proxy manager den fand ich doof den habe ich mal
ausprobiert und ich kann leider nicht mehr gesagt genau sagen was aber an der funktionsweise
gab es sachen die mir überhaupt nicht gefallen haben kann es sein dass er keine dns challenge
kann ich glaube der kann keine dns challenge das habe ich auch mal eine weile probiert
hier den nx proxy manager ist eigentlich eine coole sache moment das ist was anderes
ne das ist doch nichts anderes das ist das web interface genau der kann keine dns challenge
oder vielleicht kann er mittlerweile dns challenge also was also ich ihn ausprobieren konnte
er keine dns challenge add dns challenge nö hat er nicht und dns challenge brauche ich
also im heimbereich ist dns challenge für let's end cryptzertifikate das einfachste
und beste hatte jemand einen guten open source pdf reader
ja ich nehme immer den der im chrome eingebaut ist jeden browser ist ja mittlerweile einer
drinne so habe ich noch ein paar sachen übersehen
gerade mal kannst du ein
kannst du ein kostenloses vpn empfehlen nee nein leider nicht das haben wir schon ausprobiert
ja lief erstaunlich gut dann brauchst du kupanetes aws cluster oder kupanetes asia cluster easy
ich würde mir aber eher gedanken machen warum das alles deine geschwister sind
ja das ist so ein tick von mir ich glaube ich habe jetzt alles beantwortet was es gab
ja warum nicht ja schade ja nichts dass es alternativen gibt das habe ich jetzt noch
nicht verwendet für let's end crypt ich habe immer zertbot verwendet einzig aus schläger
greifen aus dem grund weil zertbot das erste war was ich gelernt habe und das hat immer
alles getan ja was ich haben wollte kann das denn kann das klaut flair das kann bestimmt
klaut flair oder kann das klaut flair klaut flair ich meine wenn was klaut flair nicht
kann dann ist es ja eh fail klaut flair ist das wichtigste was du können musst ja kann
klaut flair ok alles klar wie schafft man den einstieg beim programmieren das hat doch
eben das hat auch eben schon jemand gefragt bumm bar da bing bumm da bumm abonniert twitch
prime zwei monate exzellent subscribt schön dankeschön brain
by the way ich muss mal gucken dass ich keine keine subs vergessen habe das wäre schlecht
manchmal über sehe ich das ganze klaut flair ist übrigens kaputt ich weiß dass wir heute
schon mehr als einen sub hatten und es zeigt nur ein sub an ok was auch immer was auch
immer steam labster treibt 5,3 k zuschauer ja exakt
das ist manchmal ein bug das ist manchmal ein bug dass das 5,3 k anzeigt also aktuell
sind es 157 was mir auch viel lieber ist als 5,3 k 5,3 k da hätte ich ja auch so den ppega
chat am start so ist das so ist das viel angenehmer gerade also wie schafft man den einstieg
ins programmieren das ist eine frage die kommt immer wieder dazu sollte ich glaube ich mal
irgendwie einen clip oder so aufnehmen den ich immer wieder posten kann wobei vielleicht
ist gar nicht so schlecht wenn ich das öfters sage weil erinnert sich auch manchmal was
ist manchmal was dran das gleiche hat aber schon jemand gefragt vorhin wir hatten das
vorhin aber war doch eben schon noch jemand gefragt ok ah nee der gleiche alles klar
also bamm 2 4 6 der einstieg ins programmieren das beste was du machen kannst ist dir erst
mal überlegen was du genau programmieren möchtest was so deine interessen sind also
sprich zu web anwendungen machen willst du windows desktop anwendungen machen willst
du auf dem server irgendwelche skripte automatisch laufen lassen also sprich was hast du vor
was ist da was ist das gebiet was dich interessiert wo du was machen willst weißt du da schon
was weil dann ist es einfacher was zu sagen allgemein gesagt wenn man also für die für
die aktuellen größeren themen mal mal uns was überlegen also möchte man desktop anwendung
machen so richtig klassische oldschool windows desktop anwendung also möchtet ihr zum beispiel
also was wie in windows taschenrechner programmieren oder sowas no limit x o zwei monate excellent
easy clap so muss das sein aber der iq des chats geht heute schon wieder in die breite
bleibt man ja so webseiten und apps ok dann ist einfach was meinst du ok fahr mal anders
meinst du mit apps smartphone apps also mit webseiten ist relativ easy da gibt es eigentlich
nix wo man lang überlegen muss java script html css das sind die technologien die du
brauchst ich würde am anfang rein beim einstieg und zum lernen noch gar nicht mit großartigen
javascript frameworks anfangen und auch nicht mit type script oder sonst was ich würde
mir erstmal ein bisschen die vanilla java also die normalen javascript grundlagen angucken
schauen wir ein bisschen die webseiten styled mit css und wie man eine moderne webseite
mit html aufbaut ohne da jetzt komische dinger wie tabellen oder so oldschool kram zu machen
so wie man da am besten also und apps mit apps bist du da gar nicht so verkehrt weil
wenn du wirklich mal sagst ok ich möchte eine smartphone app basteln sei es jetzt für
ios oder für android wenn du dich mit webanwendung ganz gut auskennst es gibt mittlerweile relativ
viele einfache möglichkeiten webanwendung quasi als app zu verpacken und aufs handy
zu bringen also du kannst smartphone anwendung mittlerweile super als webanwendung laufen
lassen und da gibt es noch sowas wie der deadlift sagt es gerade da gibt es noch sowas
wie pwa das ist so der neueste shit das ist quasi eine app die nicht aus dem app store
kommt also sprich eine pwa kann jede webseite ausliefern das ist das womit apple angefangen
hat ganz früher dass man sich webseiten auf den homescreen adden konnte mittlerweile können
pwas aber mehr also sprich du kannst eventuell sogar mit html javascript css eine pwa erstellen
die sich wie eine app verhält ohne dass du überhaupt eine app jemals über den app store
verteilen musst also das ist schon mal eine gute einstiegssache und wie man da am besten
anfängt wie steigt man am besten ins webseiten basteln an am besten wie bei allem man sucht
sich ein projekt was einen persönlich interessiert also wenn du sagst hey ich wollte schon immer
mal gucken wie man keine ahnung wie man eine webseite macht die ein video abspielt oder
irgendwie die was weiß ich was gibt es da sonst noch alles äh wir bleiben bei irgendwelchen
frontend geschichten äh wo zwei leute miteinander chatten können oder so also ich hab mir jetzt
absichtlich sachen überlegt wo man keine groß keins oder kein großartiges backend
braucht dafür ähm also sprich wenn du da irgendein projekt hast was dich interessiert
dann ist das eine gute idee auch damit anzufangen weil dann hat man auch wenn es mal nicht so
gut läuft eine motivation weil man immer vor augen hat was man was man letztendlich
machen will so und wenn man da mit dem lernen anfängt gerade javascript ist eine supersprache
zum einstieg oder auch html css dabei es gibt so unglaublich viele und auch gute youtube
kanäle tutorialsachen die sich damit beschäftigen ich würde dir allerdings empfehlen dir was
auf englisch anzugucken weil es da einfach mehr ressourcen gibt äh johnny tell more
voice tutorial ja da haben wir uns auch schon ein paar videos angeguckt die sind tatsächlich
ganz gut wenn man es unbedingt auf deutsch haben will allerdings ich würde empfehlen
sich prinzipiell programmier tutorials und sonstige sachen auf englisch anzugucken es
hat nämlich den großen vorteil weil du den ganzen kram dann auf englisch schon im kopf
hast dir fällt es viel leichter in der suchmaschine oder bei stackoverflow nach problemen zu suchen
wenn du sie hast wenn du es schon in englisch in deinem kopf hast weil es gibt keine deutschsprachige
programmier community großartig im internet die man jetzt irgendwie mit stackoverflow
vergleichen könnte ich weiß gar nicht ob es mal einen versuch gab eines deutschen stackoverflows
kein schimmer aber es gibt einfach nix vergleichbares deswegen kann ich nur den kram auf englisch
und gut ist und es gibt auf youtube jede menge videos und tutorials und einstiegskurse da
kann ich jetzt kein spezielles empfehlen außer also channel den ich immer gerne guck ist
meint wie heißt das den kann ich mir nämlich merken weil der weil der auch max heißt die
gucke ich immer ganz gern ich weiß so dass er auch max heißt deswegen kann ich mir den
channel merken das ist aber eher was die beschäftigen sich allgemein mit mit frontend technologie die
gucke ich aber immer ganz gerne so und wenn du dann den einstieg hinter dir hast dass du
so ein bisschen dich in javascript css html auskennst dann würde ich mir überlegen ob
ich mir nicht noch vue js angucke aber erst danach ich finde für einsteiger ist vue js
das beste javascript framework was es gibt und auch für nicht einsteiger ich bin ja
vue js fanboy und das in kombination ist top also mit vue js kannst du wirklich frontend
mäßig relativ einfach super anwendungen basteln die auch relativ relativ komplexe logik haben
und was nicht total aus artet aus artet wie in vanilla javascript ja das das würde ich
das würde ich dir empfehlen ja und eine sache die ich jetzt noch vergessen habe je nachdem
was für webanwendungen du bauen willst brauchst du ja nicht nur den frontend sondern auch
einen backend und da kommt es echt auf persönliche präferenz an also sprich frontend ist das
was im browser läuft und backend ist das was letztendlich deine die logik auf dem server
macht also sprich von irgendwo wo du deine daten her kriegst solange es nicht eine anwendung
ist also zum beispiel hier sowas wie drawio ist komplett frontend da brauchst du keinen
backend server hast du jetzt natürlich sowas wie twitch dann ist ja klar die streams müssen
ja irgendwo ausgeliefert werden das kommt vom backend das hier ist frontend so und je
nachdem was du für eine anwendung machen willst brauchst du auch ein backend also ich sag mal
so 95 prozent der webanwendung haben in irgendeiner art und weise noch ein backend und auch nur
für alternifizierungen kleinigkeiten oder irgendwas und dafür ist wirklich persönliche
präferenz was du dafür programmiersprache nimmst wenn du eh schon mit javascript anfängst
kannst du auch mit node.js auf den backend anfangen und auch javascript lernen ja das
haben wir jetzt sehr ausführlich behandelt php php so sehr php gehatet wird ne asp.net
an sich sollte man nicht mehr benutzen sag ich gleich was zu so gerne php auch gehatet
wird php hat einen unklauen unschätzbaren vorteil php läuft auf jedem noch so billigen
holster wenn du irgendwas in dotnet machst oder meinetwegen in ruby ruby oder in pyson
oder sonst was dann finde erst mal einen richtig billigen lowend holster der das kann natürlich
kannst du dir immer noch eine hetzenerkiste was auch immer mieten und darauf machen was
du willst aber php ist gar nicht so schlecht wenn man das einfach bei irgendeinem holster
hinschmeißen will und laufen haben will dann ist php immer noch super und mit sowas
wie laravel in verbindung ist php auch echt angenehm zu verwenden vielleicht erinnert
sich da eine andere noch ich hatte ja mal einen battlefield 4 server mit statistikseite
keine ahnung ob da irgendjemand von euch drauf gespielt hat und diese statistikseite
vom battlefield 4 server also sprich wer hat die meisten kills welches squad ist am besten
solche geschichten das war damals eine laravel anwendung im backend die das gemacht hat
es war eine mysql datenbank weil das nitrado hatte glaube ich nur eine mysql nee war das
nitrado das war nitrado eine mysql datenbank und das backend war laravel hat auch wunderbar
funktioniert und es lief halt auf jedem holster so und die frage ist sollte man eher mit
asp.net sollte man eher asp.net benutzen nee das ist auf keinen fall weil asp.net ist
tot wenn du asp.net core meinst dann ja das ist auch mein persönliches lieblings backend
web framework es ist ja kein web framework also mein lieblings backend web framework
doch heißt ja so aber das liegt bei mir daran weil ich dotnet generell c sharp mag wenn
jemand python mag nimmt er flask für kleine sachen oder django für größere sachen wenn
einer ruby mag nimmt er sinatra für kleine sachen oder ruby and rails für große sachen
wenn einer node.js mag nimmt er was nimmt man da express oder was ist was ist denn bei
node.js so ein typisches backend gedöns express und für kleine express immer express node.js
keine ahnung wie gesagt php nehme ich meistens laravel und was gibt es denn sonst noch so
was gibt es denn sonst noch so für großartige web frameworks backend mäßig java ja java
habe ich keine ahnung was es da für backend frameworks gibt wirklich keine ahnung was
bei java für backend sachen gibt bei go habe ich gerade vergessen wie das heißt weil viele
go programme so einen komplett beknackten namen haben iris oder so hieß das oder ist
das nicht iris bei go iris kann das sein gibt es das ich glaube bei go war das das was
recht beliebt ist ja keine ahnung mehr fallen mir jetzt aus dem kopf nicht ein hast du
mal vba programmiert ja aber nur ganz wenig ich hab mal nicht vba sondern vb6 ich hab
mal einen kurs gemacht als ich noch jünger war also als ich noch in die schule gegangen
bin habe ich mal einen vb6 kurs gemacht habe ich mich extra für angemeldet oder haben
wir ein v da haben wir wischl basing 6 gemacht in wischl studio was weiß ich 5 oder was
das war oder keine ahnung ob das vb6 war das ist es ist lange her das war das war das wird
so da war half life grad aktuell das wird so 99 gewesen sein wir haben dann wir haben
dann im vb6 programmierkurs am ende immer half life gespielt wenn wir fertig waren
auf einer vb6 und waren das aktuell wann kam vb6 raus ja wischl basic 6 ja das war vb6 was
wir gelernt haben damals ja ja genau und soll ich euch mal was sagen so sehr so sehr ich
ja wischl basic an sich nicht mag für das was es sein wollte nämlich einfaches ui geklicke
mit ein bisschen logik hinter den den schaltflächen war vb6 gar nicht mal so schlecht also ich
habe schon deutlich schlimmere sachen gesehen als vb6 zum beispiel c++ so schlecht ist vb6
gar nicht gewesen ich mein ich würde mit vb6 im leben nicht
irgendeine größere anwendung basteln aber für das was es sein wollte oder für das
was es war ein bisschen gui zusammen geklicke und einfache funktion war vb6 gar nicht so
übel ich mein schlechter als c++ gehts eh nicht
mehr moin frozen offischel was ist vb6 offischel basic 6 wie gesagt legacy technologie vb6 c++
auf jeden fall es ist alles es ist alles außer brainfuck vielleicht größer c++ c++ ist
einfach der größte rotz überhaupt und brauchen brauchen mal noch sql ja sql braucht man auch
ab und zu noch allerdings wird man selten noch klassischen sql queries programmieren
es ist aber nicht verkehrt zu wissen was passiert also die zeiten wo man manuell c größer
c++ ja eindeutig aber sowas von ist c größer c++ aber die zeiten wo man die meisten queries
von hand schreibt sind vorbei also in fast jeder ordentlichen programmiersprache oder
in fast jedem ordentlichen web framework wenn es nicht wie gesagt dabei ist gibt es einen
datenbank mapper der das für dich generiert das sql also du arbeitest dann eigentlich
nur noch auf der logischen ebene dass du sagst hey datenbank objekt ich will jetzt alle user
haben also du brauchst dann kein select name firstname lastname birthdate from users sondern
das baut das für dich im hintergrund zusammen hat mit sql in excess programmiert in excess
ok excess ist natürlich noch mal pains champ aber sql können schadet nichts wie gerade
schon der der echte gll gesagt hat sql bisschen zu verstehen ist auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt
muss aber sagen ich glaube die letzten jahre habe ich keine zeile sql mehr von hand geschrieben
ich habe mir sachen angeguckt was generiert wurde und auch festgestellt dass manche sachen
ziemlich wir sind aber wirklich sql abfragen die dann auch benutzt wurden irgendwann habe
ich glaube fällt mir jetzt kein beispiel ein wo ich das die letzten jahre mal gemacht
habe außer vielleicht mal wenn ich ein sql datei geöffnet habe im sql explorer und irgendwas
schnell angucken wollte aber in keinem programm ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht ob ihr noch
in ob ihr in letzter zeit mal sql von hand geschrieben habt ich glaube die wenigsten
wahrscheinlich das ist nicht mehr so angesagt gerade maria db mongo db gut sie hat zwei
komplett unterschiedliche paar schuhe ne aber ist beides noch angesagt na maria db ist ja
mehr oder weniger mai sql und mongo db ist halt immer noch die größte neu sql datenbank
kommt in dieser klausur in sql anfragen wie gesagt die bisschen die logik dahinter verstehen
zu haben verstanden zu haben ist ja nicht verkehrt und dass man weiß dass es einen join gibt
dass man weiß was muss eigentlich im hintergrund alles gemacht werden wenn man jetzt sagt okay
ich habe ein user objekt dem gehört ein bestellungsobjekt und das sind zwei unterschiedliche tabellen
und vielleicht noch irgendwie noch eine mapping tabelle dazwischen dann ist es nicht verkehrt
wenn man das programmiert zu wissen okay was macht so eine datenbank im hintergrund beziehungsweise
wie sieht so ein sql query aus dass ich mich manchmal dann auch nicht wundern muss warum
ist es denn so langsam ich persönlich schwöre ja für die meisten sachen auf sql light ich
mag einfach sql light ja also ich bin bis ich kenne keine no sql datenbank mit der man
so einfach arbeiten kann wie mit sql light sql light ist halt die schöne sache wenn du
anwendung hast die quasi einfach laufen wenn du sie startest also wir reden jetzt nicht
von irgendeinem datenbank server der irgendwo laufen muss da ist halt so ein sql light feil
dabei zu haben beziehungsweise anzunehmen ist halt echt praktisch und solange das single
user beziehungsweise multi user auf auf einem rechner ist ihr werdet lachen was alles sql
light verwendet ja also die die meisten anwendungen oder einen riesigen teil der anwendung die
ihr so habt hat eine sql light datenbank im hintergrund irgendwo ja also mich würde es
nicht wundern wenn es das nvidia geforce control center irgendwo eine sql light anwendung
hätte zum beispiel für die spiele die es bei euch auf der platte erkannt hat oder wenn
die logitech gaming software irgendwie sql light datenbank im hintergrund hätte um settings
oder was auch immer fragt mich nicht auszulesen obs für irgendwelche sachen elgato für
irgendwelche aufnahmen also sehr viele desktop anwendung haben der sql light datenbank dabei
und die meisten sachen brauchen keinen fetten datenbank server wir reden jetzt nicht hier
von anwendungen die verteilt laufen oder wo viele user drauf zugreifen sondern einfach
nur sachen wo es halt praktisch ist eine datenbank zu haben aber wo man halt keine extra datenbank
server haben will also 99 prozent meiner sachen nehmen einfach immer sql light und gut ist
ich glaube alles was ich bisher auf github auch habe also ich weiß ich bin nicht so eifrig
im aktualisieren was mein github angeht alles sql light netdb ist eine geile alternative
wer no sql version von sql light sucht kenne ich nicht was ich halt auch an sql light gut
finde ist dass das ökosystem da drum ganz gut ist also sprich es gibt einen ordentlichen
sql light datenbank browser und man kann sql light datenbank auch relativ einfach reparieren
wenn man da ja ungültige sachen reingebastelt hat ich finde sql light ist ja praktisch gibt's
ein gutes baukastenprogramm für webseiten entwickeln shopify für shops also wenn du
ein web shop machen willst dann shopify kostet halt was man umsonst ist da nix ansonsten
habe ich mich damit ewig nicht mehr beschäftigt was gibt es für guten ich meine früher gab
so ein geschiss wie frontpage das gibt's ja glücklicherweise nicht mehr danach gab's
mal ganz gut expression web oder wie das hieß von microsoft ich meine wer wer richtig
old school ist er wird noch hier wird noch dream view wie wir kennen kann auch einer
makromedia kennt das noch jemand makromedia dreamview dreamweaver zum webseiten zusammen
klicken das ist das ist richtig old school 2004 genau das war das erste programm wo
ich angefangen habe webseiten zu basteln drin und ich habe es lange zeit verwendet
richtig boomer massif boomer und ich habe lange zeit verwendet auch danach noch weil
der html editor echt gut war das hatte für die damalige zeit die mit abstand beste autocompletion
für html überhaupt und css ja gut und natürlich gibt es ja noch so weil hier gerade eine typo
3 sagt du kannst auch so sachen wie wie gesagt irgendwelche cms wordpress wordpress zum beispiel
ja also wenn du wirklich was haben willst wo du einfach nur zum größten teil content
editierst auf einer webseite die ganz gut aussieht dann nimmst du dir den wordpress
suchst du dir ein angenehmes wordpress theme vielleicht noch ein paar plugins die du brauchst
und dann schreibst du halt deinen content dafür musst du nicht programmieren lernen
wenn du allerdings programmieren lernen willst also wenn dein ziel nicht ist ich möchte
eine webseite machen die einfach nur ganz passabel aussieht mit ein bisschen text drauf wenn
du wirklich programmieren lernen willst dann ist sowas wie wordpress nix gibt es das überhaupt
noch oh gott wenn ich das sehe da krieg ich ja ausschläge schon schumler habe in der
schule html in notepad plus plus gelernt immerhin war es nicht notepad notepad plus plus ich
weiß nicht mehr wie diese editor hieß den ich früher neben dream viewer verwendet habe
es gab so einen richtigen so richtigen boomer editor damals also von der zeit her für html
und es war nicht dream viewer es war simpel html wie hieß das es gab einen editor der
war voll der war voll im trend bei möchte gern webseite webseiten hexorn ja webseiten
autor nämlich programmieren konnte man das nicht nennen was wir damals getrieben haben
nicht nano war das html plus plus nein ps pad war das ps pad das könnte tatsächlich
ps pad gewesen sein das könnte das könnte tatsächlich ps pad gewesen sein irgendwas
was uralt ist initial release 2001 ja ok das kommt hin nee nee das war in den editor
war nur für html ja das könnte sein ja ich glaube das ding meine ich jaja genau genau
das meine ich das meine ich face 5 richtig genau das face 5 das war damals der neueste
der neueste shit ich glaube face 5 war das wann kam das raus initiale version von ja
das kommt hin das kommt hin das war für die leute die gesagt haben wie ich soll da in
dream viewer ab und zu mal rumklicken die richtig coolen leute das alles nur noch in
dem editor ja aber heute würde ich das nicht mehr verwenden wenn ich heute was verwenden
müsste dann eindeutig visual studio code und fertig das also die frage stellt sich
heute nicht mehr das problem hat sich gelöst also wenn man einfach nur den editor haben
will da funktioniert und super ist für frontendentwicklung dann nimmt man einfach visual studio code eventuell
noch die ein oder anderen kleinen plugins zum beispiel für für für css farben oder
so aber das war es fertig das ist gelöstes problem
welches baujahr bist du eigentlich ja rate mal was meinst du denn
was meinst du denn weil ich geboren bin ein paar im chat nicht nicht spoilern chat nicht
spoilern
ja nicht schlecht also der chat der chat der chat spoilert ja schon ein bisschen also ich
bin grad 35 kann man ausrechnen ich bin 1984 geboren
ich bin glaube ich einer der wenigen 35 jährigen der abends auf twitch sitzt und sachen wie
tech weh oder oder pepo fett von sich gibt der twitch tv memes mag und sich irgendwelche
resitas emote meme compilations anguckt
aber es gibt immer mehr ohne scheiß es also bei einer sache bin ich wirklich froh dass
ich in der zeit lebe wo ich jetzt hier bin die ha wie sage ich also die die erwartung
an sich selbst und die die umwelt an einen hat was man denn wie man denn zu sein hat
oder was man nicht sein sollte in einem gewissen alter das gibt es heute in der art und weise
oder es ist mir es ist mir egal ja also ich hatte früher von erwachsenen leuten ein ganz
anderes bild wie was ich jetzt bin weiß ich auch versteht was ich meine ja also ich mein
klar wie ich jung war konnte ich gar nicht dran denken mit 35 sitzt du vorm rechner sagst
keck w weil ich hätte keine ahnung dass es in rechner gibt dass es twitch gibt dass es
keck w gibt also ist ja klar aber man hat sich ja früher schon so ausgeweilt okay wie
muss wie sind leute so mit 35 hat leute auch gesehen in dem alter wie die sind die waren
halt so so so voll ernst und erwachsen und so so so boomer mäßig halt alle ja und heute
ist das nicht mehr nicht mehr so wild erstens ist es total egal es hat auch eine weile gedauert
erstens ist mir das egal selbst wenn sich da irgendwie einer drüber lustig machen würde
warum ich aus versehen mal pock sage oder so rutscht mir auf der arbeit manchmal raus
neue servers sind da pock so und also erstens juckt es mich nicht und zweitens ist das in
der heutigen zeit schon wirklich viel besser als es früher war ich hab zumindest hab ich
persönlich den eindruck dass es dass es früher viel festgefahrener war quasi wie es halt
ist wenn man wenn man ein gewisses alter hat und heute ist es sind die leute zumindest
habe ich den eindruck ja es ist viel sind die leute viel freier quasi in dem wie sie
sich entfalten können und auch viel es wird auch weniger es wird auch weniger gelästert
so nach dem motto guck mal hier was weiß ich der ist 35 und hat einen komischen frosch
auf dem t-shirt oder so und ich meine ich habe ja meinen ich habe ja öfters mal mein
monka s t-shirt an oder oder irgendwie guck mal hier da ist 35 und und macht da irgendwelche
internetgeschichten und so und du bist dort generell viel viel freier in der entfaltung
ich mein guck mal heute kannst du dich hinstellen sagen leute ich bin schwul juckt kein mehr
das war vor 35 jahren noch nicht so breit akzeptiert wie man das heute für komplett
normal nimmt ja und zum größten klar pc lust es gibt immer noch leute das juckt aber
die meisten ist das vollkommen egal oder der trend geht eindeutig dahin dass es bald
wenn der rest ausgestorben ist wirklich vollkommen wirklich den 95 vollkommen egal ist und das
trifft natürlich auf andere aspekte auch zu das heißt die leute sind heute viel weniger
voreingenommen was das angeht mit einer heute ist es quasi die norm von der norm abzuweichen
wisst ihr wie ich mein früher wurdest du scherb angeguckt heute bist du quasi wenn du weiß
männlich heterosexuell fleischfresser bist männlich und die norm darstellt wirst du schon
scherb angeguckt warum die die norm bist so also heute ist es viel einfacher von der norm
abzuweichen und die norm an sich gibt es ja gibt es ja auch irgendwie gar nicht mehr so richtig das
ist viel angenehmer heute das ist nicht so wie ich mir das früher als ich jung war vorgestellt
habe wie es sein wird wenn man mal 35 ist viel besser viel viel besser als ich mir das vorgestellt
habe heute wirst du nicht scherb angeguckt wenn du sagst leute ich bin 35 ich verdiene mein
geld einmal halt mit it zeug und ich verdiene mein geld mit youtube videos mit streams auf
twitch und ich sitze den ganzen tag vorm rechner und und laber irgendwie vier stunden mit leuten
oder so klar dann bist du okay du wirst da du wirst schon scherb angeguckt weil die meisten
leute keinen platzen schimmer haben was was du eigentlich machst ja also man wird schon schräg
angeschaut aber es baut keinen druck in dem sinn auf so richtig wenn du wirst dann halt
scherb angeschaut die leute sagen wir so wie her damit kann man geld verdienen das war es
da du hast noch genug intolerante leute die sagen oh max jetzt wird es aber langsam mal
zeit hier zack zack familiegründen frau kinder auf gehts hier kann ich einfach sagen kann mich
keiner zu zwingen das nur weil sowas früher halt als norm angesehen wurde juckt das heute
kein mal großartig nähe ich mache auf youtube wenig in letzter zeit das letzte glaube ich
drei monate her oder wann ist das letzte video war zwei monate ok fast drei monate ja also ich
finde es viel angenehmer in der heutigen zeit zu leben wie sie wirklich ist als ich wie als sich
ich sie mir vorgestellt habe wie ich jünger war ja so sieht es aus
es ist eher umgedreht dass du heute teilweise dazu gezwungen wirst
ja dass du eher schäb angeguckt wirst wenn du mal mainstream bist bei irgendwas hast du eine
frau freunde nähe das das mit dem weihnachtsgrill war ja nix der chat weiß bescheid das ist auch
schon wieder ein jahr her jetzt aber eine sache werde ich nie wieder machen das habe ich auch
schon im stream gesagt eine sache werde ich nie wieder machen was was was dieses thema hier
angeht und zwar nie wieder internetmedels also ich habe nichts dagegen wenn leute da irgendwie sich
übers internet kennenlernen und sich treffen und alles funktioniert aber das gebe ich mir nicht
mehr tinder alles in ordnung habe ich alles in ordnung was ich mein ist folgendes quasi sich
online kennenlernen sich gut verstehen und dann quasi schon bevor man sich getroffen hat stress
machen mit so dingern also mit mit keine ahnung oh nee ich kann mich jetzt nicht treffen weil
x und sonst was das werde ich nie wieder mitmachen so blödsinn nie wieder ich habe mir das zwei
mal fast ein halbes jahr gegeben das mache ich nie wieder
also die melde ich übers internet besser kennengelernt habe das war eher das war sehr
viel war sehr belastend und stressig es ist überhaupt kein problem wenn man wenn man sich
übers internet kennenlernt und wenn man sagt ok wir verstehen uns ja gut lasst uns mal treffen
weil es ist einfach ein riesen unterschied ob man sich gegenüber sitzt oder ob man im chat macht
wisst ihr wie ich mein und das schlimmste ich glaube ich habe ich weiß nicht ob ich schon
mal erzählt habe ja zu zeiten wo ich wo ich wo ich youtube schon schon youtube gemacht habe
da habe ich auch mal ein im internet kennengelernt weiß gar nicht wie es wie es dazu gekommen ist
ich glaube über twitter war das und wir haben auch ein paar wochen so rum geschrieben haben uns
eigentlich ganz gut ganz gut verstanden habe ich auch gesagt ja hier lasst du mal was spricht
dagegen lasst doch mal irgendwie müssen in der stadt treffen beim 246 dankeschön für den primes
ab so und da hat sie immer irgendwelche ausreden gehabt so nach dem motto auch nie was weiß ich
warum das jetzt mit treffen nicht funktioniert habe ich schon etwas irgendwas stimmt hier nicht
ja irgendwas irgendwas ist hier merkwürdig aber auf der anderen seite hat sie da teilweise zeugs
geschrieben wo ich mir gedacht habe am liebsten am liebsten will sie eines bespringen oder so oder
umgedreht so ganz merkwürdig ja auf der einen seite nie nie grad treffen geht nicht aber ja
würde ich voll gerne und dann gehen als sie irgendwie so ein bisschen ihre fantasien da
ausgelebt im internet ja und irgendwann das das das ging dann auch so eine ganze weile wir haben
auch regelmäßig voice chatten und so habe ich mir okay ich ich kann jetzt so auf den ersten
blick eigentlich nix erkennen wo ich sagen würde ja mit der stimmt irgendwas nicht aber ich habe
mir die ganze zeit okay das ist doch nicht normal dass dass sie sich da immer rausredet auf der
einen seite so attacke machen und dann auf der anderen seite auch nie treffen ja aber ihr geht
jetzt nicht und wisst ihr was was da rausgekommen ist am ende nee kein fake nein kein fake die war
weder gefakt noch echt ich bin ja da eh seitdem ich youtube mache eh vorsichtig was was irgendwelche
leute gibt die mich anschreiben und so was nee nee an der war nichts fake die gab es das war kein
mann oder sonst was das was dann rausgekommen ist bloß die war verheiratet
so und deswegen die wollte ein bisschen ihre fantasien ausleben quasi aber nee ohne kinder
ohne kinder hat sie zumindest gesagt vielleicht wer weiß und wie alt ich habe damals schon
youtube gemacht dass das wird das wird so 2012 oder 2011 oder so gewesen sein
22 da war ich keine ahnung da war ich irgendwie ich sage jetzt einfach irgendwie 27 oder so und
die war übrigens auch zehn jahre älter als sie geschrieben hat habe ich ja noch ganz habe ich
noch ganz vergessen ich war irgendwie 26 oder so und sie hat gesagt sie ist 21 und sie hat sich
auch immer mit rausgeredet ihre eltern wollen das nicht dass irgendwie sonst was zumindest ich war
irgendwie 26 und sie hat gesagt sie ist 21 sondern am ende oder ich war 27 frag mir nicht keine ahnung
irgendwie so in dem dreh halt ich habe wie gesagt ich habe schon youtube gemacht und am ende kam
raus die war zehn jahre älter die war nicht 21 sondern 31 und verheiratet alter und was die
für nachrichten geschrieben hat das ist monka tos das kann ich jetzt erstens will ich das jetzt
hier nicht so breit reden weil es letztendlich ja auch eine private geschichte und zweit aber
es wäre es auch ziemlich monka tos das hat so überhaupt nicht zusammengepasst von was die was
die so schreibt weil ich meine wir haben ja gewoist chat die gewoist chat also sprich ich wusste
dass die quasi echt ist an sich und was sie so schreibt zu oh nee geht jetzt alles nicht und
sonst was und ja also ganz ganz merkwürdig ganz ganz merkwürdig auf jeden fall und näher
das das ging halt eine ganze weile so ein halbes jahr oder so ich bin auch irgendwann gedacht
habe nie also irgendwas stimmt hier nicht dann ist das ganze ja auch rausgekommen und das war
so das letzte mal wo ich mir gedacht habe alle die mehls über das internet das nähe wie kam
das raus wie kam das raus
weiß das kann ich mir mal wie kam das wie kam das raus
irgendwas ist schief gelaufen ich krieg das ich krieg das gar nicht mehr so richtig zusammen
zumindest hat es dann halt erzählt und das geile war ja dass ich sogar mal aus spaß im
vorfeld gesagt habe wo sie dann erzählte da nie treffen geht nicht wo ich dann gesagt habe
wo sie dann irgendwie wo ich dann irgendwie zu ihr so aus spaß gesagt hat ja gab es zu du bist
du bist du bist in wirklichkeit verheiratet und hat sie dann da geschrieben nee nee nee nee
und da habe ich halt eigentlich schon so quasi nach dem zweiten mal wo ich eigentlich genau
in schwarze getroffen unwissentlich wie ist denn das rausgekommen ich weiß das gar nicht
mehr genau ich kann mich dran erinnern wurde ich wurde ich das dann erzählt hat keine ahnung ich
weiß immer das ist das ja auch schon acht jahre oder sieben sieben jahre oder so her oder das war
das letzte mal wo ich mir gesagt wo ich übers internet das nee das mache ich nicht mehr
hat der man das rausgehunden fast fast ach ja doch ich glaube das könnte sogar gewesen sein
wie es rauskommen ist die hat anstatt mir zu schreiben aus versehen ihrem kerl geschrieben
ich wusste ja nicht dass es den gibt und die hat sich die hat sich bei mit mit ein message
vertan und dann kam das irgendwie frag mich nicht alles schon ist schon ewig ewig her
und alles hat mit 10 plus plus angefangen ich weiß auch nicht ob wir da jetzt drauf
gekommen sind aber elotrix klärt sich auch die ganzen girls und milfs übers internet
jeder wie er mag und jeder wie er kann und jeder wie er sich vielleicht auch manche
sache nur ausgedacht hat gegen irgendwelche seiten wo man leute kennenlernen kann oder
gegen irgendwelche tinder match geschichten oder sowas ist auch vollkommen in ordnung
dann sieht man sich wenigstens und dann erkennt man auch ob das funktioniert oder nicht es hat
keinen sinn und wie gesagt ich spreche da aus erfahrung es hat echt keinen sinn wenn man da
irgendwie wochenlang texte schreibt voice chattet was auch immer also das wichtigste ist erstmal
wirklich jemand übers internet kennenlernen erstmal so schnell wie es geht wenn man sich
ganz sympathisch voice chat voice chat klärt schon mal viel ab ob man überhaupt miteinander
klarkommt und danach man muss sich relativ schnell treffen weil es hat wirklich keinen
sinn wenn man sich irgendwie hier über den chat gut versteht oder im voice chat beim
frag mich mein kraft spielen gut versteht das heißt noch lange nicht dass man sich
irgendwie anziehend findet wenn man sich in echt sieht null oder kann man auch gar nichts
gegen machen selbst wenn man selbst wenn man irgendwelche photos gesehen hat im vorfeld ist
das keine garantie dafür also wenn er sie wenn er dir gegenüber steht oder halt keinerlei
gegenseitige anziehung verspürt dann bringt es weder voice chat noch noch chat dass man sich
da verstanden hat auf der anderen seite es gibt genug leute wo das funktioniert hat überlegt
mal wie viele leute sich in world of warcraft oder mmo's kennengelernt haben die heute verheiratet
sind mit kinder und allem am start gibt gibt's ja und auch diese auch auch aktuell diese diese
tinder geschichte warum nicht ich mein ich habe es so nicht persönlich nicht ausprobiert aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass tinder eigentlich eine super geschichte ist weil du dir von Anfang an
im klaren bist erstens was die leute wollen oder nicht wollen ja vielleicht suchen die leute ja
nur jemand anderes für spezielle sachen aber du siehst zumindest gleich schon mal was sache ist
du hast ein bild von einem vor dir du weißt da kommt aus der nähe was ja auch schon mal wichtig
ist und du kannst und die meiste leute wollen sich dann auch treffen dafür ist diese matching
geschichte mit kinder noch eine super geschichte was soll das doch top das nimmt total viel über
über wie so über überzeugt über überwindung kostet das viel weniger so hydrant zwölf monat
dankeschön excellent ich meine es ist doch viel ist doch viel einfacher in tinder zu
wischen und zu sagen jawoll gefällt mir gefällt mir nicht als rl wenn man noch gar nicht genau
weiß wer das andere so ist und und ob man sich gefällt oder sonst was da auf jemanden zuzugehen
das ist doch mit tinder das nimmt auch so das nimmt auch sehr viel chancen raus wo schief gehen kann
ist doch eigentlich für alle beteiligt nicht verkehrt ja man über tinder da jetzt irgendwie
die große liebe findet keine ahnung aber an sich finde ich sowas nicht verkehrt ist eigentlich
eine super geschichte und mich wundert das doch nicht dass noch nicht früher einer auf die idee
gekommen ist sowas wie tinder zu basteln eigentlich richtige big brain ab idee wo ich mich frage warum
ist da nicht schon früher einer drauf gekommen ja ja machst gut ja siehst du bambabam voice chat
nennt man ja früher hat man voice chat auch telefonieren genannt das stimmt naja das ist
gar nicht wie wir da drauf gekommen sind aber das das habe ich mir da an dem zeitpunkt ich
nehme dass das diese art und weise war ich das nicht mehr und außerdem muss man sagen früher also wenn
man wenn man als man noch ein bisschen jünger war bei manchen sachen war man auch echt doof
bei manchen sachen war man auch echt doof also man hat sich teilweise schon absichtlich verarschen
lassen und man muss es erst mal selbst erkennen ja das das ist das das ist das wichtigste ja zum
beispiel oder was was was jemand zum beispiel wenn wenn versucht wird einem irgendwie ein schlechtes
gewissen zu machen dass man angeblich kann dass man angeblich irgendwas irgendwas gemacht hätte
ja und so nach dem motto was hast was hast was hast du gemacht oder sonst was und genau zum
beispiel hat eine mal gesagt so nach dem motto sie würde nie wieder mit mir reden was ist ich
weiß ich weiß überhaupt nicht ich weiß überhaupt nicht was ist ja und damals muss ich sagen war
ich noch so blöd zu erkennen dass das eigentlich nur taktik war wahrscheinlich wollte checken wie
ich reagiere oder so keine ahnung und ich war damals halt so bescheuert und habe gesagt was ist
denn los erzähl mal ich bin ja quasi so voll auf die pelle gerückt so nach dem motto ich wollte
jetzt raus bekommen was ist ja und was man eigentlich hätte machen müssen ist zu sagen ok ich
ich weiß nicht was jetzt los ist also ich bin mir da irgendwie nichts nichts bewusst aber sach
bescheid wenn du dich wieder beruhigt hast weil durch das durch das einschleimen in solchen
situationen erreicht man denke ich nur das gegenteil dass die andere seite denkt so nach dem motto man
kann einfach mal irgendwas raushauen und kann den anderen so unter druck setzen oder mal gucken was
er macht im prinzip ist es so ich würde nicht sagen einfach ignorieren aber heute würde ich
wahrscheinlich sagen okay keine ahnung was es geht aber sag bescheid ja wenn du nicht wenn es
wenn wieder alles normal ist keine ahnung aber das sind so solche sachen da ist man später da ist man
wenn man ein bisschen älter ist ein bisschen schlauer damals war ich halt auch so blöd und
hab dann wirklich noch voll rumgeschleimt so nach dem motto alter was was ist denn ich verstehe
überhaupt nicht was du willst jetzt erzähl doch mal lass uns mal zusammensetzen einfach sagen
muss ok sag bescheid wenn du dich beruhigt hast und es hätte nicht lange gedauert es hätte keine
ahnung drei stunden zwei stunden später hätte ich wahrscheinlich angerufen
ja frau tun fraude ja so ungefähr
das sind so sachen das wäre ja nie verstehen total das ist auch sachen da hab ich echt keinen
bock drauf so irgendwelche so irgendwelche austestspielchen so wie weit kann man sonst
wie gehen und wie psychisch unter druck setzen kann man jemand dass er das tut was ich will dass
er tut oder dass sie tut das ist keine keine basis irgendwie wo ich mir das auf längere zeit
vorstellen kann es gibt leute sowohl männliche als auch weibliche die das probieren aber das
macht keinen irgendwie glücklich denke ich wenn das total un ausgewogen ist das ist quasi
kindergarten wenn einer alles macht der andere nix und immer mit immer mit der androhung so nach dem
motto ja morgen könnte ich ja auch weg sein es gibt ja so leute wie gesagt ist egal ob männlich
oder weiblich ich persönlich habe den eindruck es ist bei frauen häufiger allerdings liegt das
bei mir natürlich auch ein bisschen durch die rosa rote prille weil ich bin halt ein kerl wenn
man sachen immer wenn man forderung immer mit dem dem dem nach druck unter mauer zu nach dem motto
morgen könnte man weg sein oder oder wer weiß was man das ist keine grundlage für irgendwie
gutes ausgewogenes zusammenleben irgendwo was ist mit non binary geschlechter ja die auch die kann
das genauso es kann jeder den dachschaden haben und leute manipulieren wollen oder leute psychisch
fertig machen wollen es gibt genug menschen die haben da irgendwie den hang dazu vielleicht mal
andere seite ausprobieren ja vielleicht ist da besser man weiß ja nicht non binary java script
java script ist nicht nur non binary java script ist quadruple larry da gehen ja manchmal die
gleichen sachen wenn man sie mehrfach ausführt nicht nicht gleich aus und so was sobald man
gezwungen wird sich zu verändern macht es keinen sinn ich denke mal ein bisschen wie kommt ein
bisschen kompromisse eingehen glaube ich ist nicht wirklich das problem und wenn man manche
sachen nicht mehr vielleicht so oft machen kann wie man kann das ist alles das muss muss ich aber
beidseitig irgendwie treffen ja es kann nicht sein dass einer immer alles macht und quasi von
der anderen seite komplett unter druck gesetzt wird so nach dem motto ja ich kann mir jetzt auch
jemand anderes suchen oder so leider ist es nur so und da gibt es bestimmt gibt es wahrscheinlich
sogar bestimmt irgendwelche psychologischen forschung und sonst was zu dass es leute gibt
die halt da sehr empfänglich für sind es gibt leute die machen das gerne andere leute ausnutzen
und es gibt leute für die sind dafür empfänglich ausgenutzt zu werden und solche leute ziehen das
auch gerne an die wundern sich dann immer so nach dem motto warum sind alle leute so scheiße zu mir
weil die weil die sich immer leute suchen und da dritt da kriegst du echt nachschauen dann auf
dauer also das muss das muss das muss gegenseitig sein kann ich sein dass einer alles macht der
andere nix und quasi alles bekommt weil die andere seite permanent unter druck gesetzt wird
jetzt kommen wir nur weil dann gleich gleich nun falls es ist nicht gleich die ganze sprache
schlecht die ganze sprache ist auch nicht schlecht java script geht schon das einzige was nicht geht
ist ziel plus plus der moment mal tote also ja die habe ich übers internet kennengelernt aber
das war das war nicht die von der ich erzählt habe ich finde es übrigens interessant dass
es überhaupt noch jemand kennt das einzige was noch immer als ziel plus plus ist die
dokumentation von ziel plus plus ja danach weißt du nämlich auch nicht schlauer was ziel plus
plus ist doof ja ziel plus plus sagt schlimmste programmier sprache überhaupt hast du schon mal
eine mod für den game geschrieben ja ich habe für half life 1 mal versucht einen mod beziehungsweise
eine mod mit mit einer map zu basteln und zwar ich hatte schon immer so ein bisschen den hang
dazu mich an sachen fest zu beißen die nicht funktionieren zum beispiel ich wollte unbedingt
in ich wollte unbedingt in einer half life map ein panzer oder jeep oder sonst was haben der
fährt und schießt und werden bis ihn sich mit der half life 1 engine beschäftigt hat er weiß das
ist nicht möglich es gibt in half life 1 keine fahrzeuge also es gibt in half life 1 eh keine
fahrzeuge es gibt plus es gibt plus bahnen ja plus trains also auch panzer sind sind bahnen in
half life und sobald das ein interaktives objekt ist nämlich eine bahn können sie keine schuss
trigger und sowas haben und wir haben versucht das quasi zu basteln dass das geht habe sich
hinbekommen muss ich auch gleich dazu sagen gunman hat es damals hinbekommen falls das noch jemand
kennt ja das war auch nach live 1 mod die haben es damals hinbekommen die ging das aber das war
halt auch ein komplettes team die wussten was man macht es war übrigens sehr plus plus vielleicht
habe ich da auch oder c ne ne half life 1 war auch ziemlich sicher z plus plus ja vielleicht
kommt auch daher dass ich z plus plus eklig finde also wenn ich betriebssystem mäßig
irgendwas programmieren muss achso du meinst wenn du ein betriebssystem programmieren möchtest
ja ok dann vielleicht aber selbst linux ist in c und linux hasst z plus plus aber wenn ich was
machen muss was viele betriebssystem apis verwendet es spricht nix dagegen diese sachen in c zu machen
und das dann aufzurufen auf ein bisschen höher leveligen programmiersprache oder im fall von
dort net ist ja auch interop mit c api ist relativ einfach temple os ja wie gesagt also
für half life 1 haben wir mal probiert einen mini mod mit map zu basteln
so leute ich sehe 22 20 ich muss ins bett ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten heute war
ja kompletter laber stream wir haben eigentlich nichts gemacht außer geschwätzt von anfang bis
ende wenn du willst kannst du mit sich ab auch ein os schreiben dafür wie unser da bin ich mir
gar nicht so sicher ob das geht weil ich meine du brauchst dort net runtime und wie willst du
beispielsweise dein bootloader programmieren mit einer dotnet runtime so ganz so ganz ohne c
vielleicht sogar die ein oder anderen sampler geschichten wirst du nicht auskommen wenn du
ein betriebssystem programmieren willst aber die ganzen linux ui toolkit sind entweder c plus
oder bauen die eins ja es gibt ja es gibt ja außer gnome und cute nicht wirklich großartig ja ich
weiß gibt fltk oder wie das heißt oder oder dieses andere was samsung verwendet was angeblich
absoluter bullshit sein muss aber es haben so gnome und cute ist das was es gibt der rest ist
wirklich sehr sehr niche genau die 17 libraries oder 16 libraries meine ich die dies müssen ja
wohl hin das ist auch das was samsung irgendwie unter der haupe verwendet das ist das was das
ist jenseits jenseits von von gut und böse im endeffekt gibt's gnome gnome hat quasi so
ein komisches auf c aufgesetzt das typ system das stimmt und es gibt cute sowohl gnome als
auch cute laufen theoretisch cross-platform nur dass gnome absolut keinen wert drauf legt
cross-platform zu laufen gnome also gtk besser gesagt gtk wurstet gnome wurstet in gtk rum wie
sie lustig sind da werden wildsachen die percade falls es auf dem desktop nicht mehr brauchen da
gibt es eine neue version die irgendwie komplett anders funktioniert als die alte also gtk ist
eine absolute zumutung es sei denn für gnome desktop anwendung und cute würde ich noch nicht
mal als großartiges linux ui toolkit sehen cute ist das einzige wirklich verwendbare gute
cross-platform native ui framework was es gibt sonst gibt es nix mit cute kannst du windows
anwendung machen linux anwendung mac machen die modern aussehen native laufen und als
dementsprechend auch betriebssystem sachen verwenden können 3d beschleunigte sachen verwenden können
dass ein webview hat also das einzige native du kannst sogar mobile anwendung machen das einzige
full feature native cross-platform ui framework ist cute was anderes gibt es nicht jetzt kommt
mir keiner mit elektron das ist ein browser im eigenen fenster sammarin auch nicht da ist
zum beispiel die linux unterstützung kacke und sammarin fährt den an den den ansatz wir
implementieren ui elemente nicht wie wir wollen sondern benutzen die vom betriebssystem was dazu
führt dass man nur die kleinsten gemeinsam nennen verwendet und es kacke aussieht und außerdem ist
es sammel sammel overkill zehn monate sehr rauksino dankeschön excellent subscription ich gehe jetzt
aber echt oft ich gehe jetzt echt oft ich muss pennen morgen früh arbeiten wieder wir sehen
uns macht's gut bis denn brauchen wir noch outro musik leute wx richards vergiss es all das ist
deshalb ist es gar nicht erwähnt brauche noch outro brauche noch outro musik die outro musik noch
also bis denn macht's gut zu